the father reached his hand into the
heavens and pulled down seven stars and
one by one he set them on the brow of
huger of the hill to make a glowing
crowd the maid brought him forth a girl
as supple as willow with eyes like deep
pools and Hugo declared that he would
have her for his bride so the mother
made her fertile and the kron4 told that
she would bear the king for and forty
mighty sons the warrior gave strength to
their arms whilst the Smith wrought for
each a suit of iron plates but sadly the
gods no longer walk the earth among us
and you can see what a mess we made of
their creation since yet we have hope
the gods didn't abandon us in silence
but gave us their holy words to guide us
collected in the oldest and holiest
texts of the faith of the seven the
seven pointed star divided into seven
books for the seven aspects of God in it
we learn of the father's justice the
mother's mercy
the maidens innocence the Crone's wisdom
the Warriors strength the Smith's labor
and the strangers peace it is a long
book many never read it in its entirety
even if they could when the Andals first
sail for Westeros filled with divine
fire every warrior carved a
seven-pointed star into his body or even
that was easier than carving its
namesake into his mind the one could
perhaps argue that it wasn't the
Warriors but the septons incepted armed
with the holy texts of the seven pointed
star who truly conquered Westeros the
first man had no letters but the runes
they would scratch onto rocks no gods
but the faces they would carve into
trees but then came our holy men and
women among them bearing the very words
of the gods under their arms trees and
rocks were no match for the seven
pointed star
and most of Westeros soon turned to the
faith and to its Guardians
their new Andale overlords whilst the
Andals soon fractured into warring
kingdoms the faith remained whole and
indivisible bound together by the seven
pointed star when those kingdoms fell to
Aegon and his dragons thousands of years
later the faith remains subject only to
the seven above and the seven-pointed
star below or so it was supposed to be
too often our high septons have lost
their way
clouded by worldly wealth and power no
matter we still have the seven pointed
star
men's will and virtue may fail but the
words never do as men bow to their lords
and Lords to their kings
so kings and queens must bow before the
seven who are want the knees of the
powerful work for same as the knees of
the weak and were given to all for the
same purpose to bend before the gods or
break in the bending